all right while we were waiting to hit
the other slides up I also want to
mention we did mention a thank you to
our sponsors I didn't specifically our
co-sponsors I didn't specifically
mention that we're talking about
Clearview treatment programs you can
meet their director michael roy and
other representatives they're also
silver Hill hospital where we have Amy
Grimaldi you can orient us not sure
where we're stuck while we are sorting
this out I will mention that our next
presenter dr. Anthony roko is an
assistant professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto where he's the
director of the clinical neurosciences
laboratory he's an affiliate research
scientist with the Toronto Centre for
Addiction and Mental Health he's a
prolific researcher he is clearly an
up-and-coming gonna be a leader of our
field particularly with regard to
neuropsychological impairment within
borderline personality disorder he's
already well established with grants and
and we are delighted with us
[Applause]
sorry give me a moment here all right
thank you very much sir for the quick
delay there it's very nice to be here
today and thank you for inviting me
so my name is Anthony Rocco and I came
in from Toronto last night to be here
today to talk about some of the research
that were doing in my laboratory at the
University of Toronto so I should say at
the outside that I am a clinical
neuropsychologist it was really nice to
see that the theme of this meeting was
cognitive disturbances in BPD and this
is actually the area that I specialize
in as a clinical neuropsychologist so I
recognize that many people may not be so
familiar with what I mean when I say
neuropsychological functioning so I'm
gonna review a little bit today about
what neuro psychology is and why neuro
psychology may be useful for people
people with BPD um and then talk a
little bit about how this might impact
treatment and some of the research that
we're doing funded by the American
Foundation for Suicide Prevention
that helps us potentially understand how
cognitive dysfunctions might impact
treatment for people with BPD okay so
when we talk about BPD there are a lot
of different ways and actually Gabrielle
did a great job
describing the different core symptom
dimensions of the disorder um I like to
think about the core symptoms as
revolving around three domains we can
talk about the interpersonal the
emotional but I want to highlight
impulse control because that is actually
one domain of neuropsychological
functioning that neuro psychologist like
me use when we evaluate a patient so it
could be somebody with dementia a
traumatic brain injury schizophrenia we
use cognitive tests neuropsychological
tests actually measure impulse control
so you can bet that I'm gonna be talking
a little bit about what do people with
BPD look like when we're talking about
their impulse control on these
standardized tests and one thing that I
want to point out at the outside is
you've probably heard the word cognition
before as it relates to BPD you've
probably seen it in the DSM 4 that there
are difficulties with cognition actually
it could be a component of any of the
personality disorders but cognition in
the DSM 4 is actually referring to
something different from what
neuropsychologist typically associate
with cognition so in the DSM 4 we're
normally talking about cognition as a
way that people were view the world and
themselves and the future this is
different from what we mean as
neuropsychologist when we talk about
cognition so in the DSM for cognition is
referring to things in BPD like an
unstable self-image idealizing devaluing
others paranoia when under stress these
are different from what we mean is
neuropsychologist so what do I mean well
we're talking about thinking abilities
broadly speaking in neuropsychology and
so we use these very sophisticated
instruments neuropsychological tests to
evaluate thinking abilities um and I
should point out that all of these tests
that we use have been standardized so
that there should be administer the
exact same way every time that the test
is actually given to somebody and we
actually figure out what's normal for
any given individual by giving these
tests to hundreds if not thousands of
different people to see what's average
and what's maybe superior so above
average or below average or even a
deficit or an impairment and these tests
can be used with all kinds of different
people people who are you know in
adulthood with possibly a neurologic or
a mental illness or we could been using
these with children to evaluate ADHD for
example so what are the different types
neuropsychological or cognitive
abilities that we typically evaluate as
neuropsychologists so I should point out
first of all that these are all coming
from the brain okay we assume that these
are the tests that we give of these
different abilities are all correlated
with specific parts of the brain and
different brain systems are coordinated
and involved in a lot of these different
abilities so for example one thing we
talk about is attention which is
hopefully what I've got here today right
now is your attention working memory so
your ability to actually maintain the
information that I'm telling you now in
your mind for brief periods of time
episodic memory that's your memory for
things that you may learn today and then
be able to recall them tomorrow you've
probably heard of the term executive
function and it's actually a complex
term that we'll be talking a little bit
more about in a moment and it's
basically a term that refers to
higher-level thinking abilities that
rely on a lot of these other functions
and this is something that's
particularly relevant to BPD so if you
hear me talk about this more in a moment
we also have visual spatial abilities so
if you're able to navigate the streets
to get here today then you've probably
got intact visual spatial abilities
motor abilities like tapping your finger
to your fingers to your thumb and then
perceptual abilities so being able to
perceive things in your environment now
some of these things are gonna be more
relevant to BPD and some of them will
not be as relevant but I want to point
out that we usually evaluate all of
these domains to try to figure out how
they might be impacting somebody's life
okay so I had to strike a balance here
between actually showing you the test
that we use to evaluate these abilities
and protecting their confidentiality and
privacy because the most of them are
copyrighted tests but I want to give you
a flavor of what we typically do to
evaluate evaluate these domains and I'm
gonna go into talking about what do we
actually see in people with BPD all
right so when we're talking about
attention and concentration one test for
me here would be seeing you
is anybody dozing off hopefully you're
not and you're paying close attention to
this brief attention is one aspect of
attention that we measure this is
actually looking at things like asking
you to repeat a series of digits so I
might say four three nine seven two and
then you have to repeat it back to me so
this is a measure of brief attention so
you may have heard of you know this type
of a thing is a measure of short-term
memory that's okay to say that many
people use that term for this type of a
test but we're usually referring to as
neuropsychologist this is an attention
test or it sustained attention this is
obviously the ability to sustain your
attention for long periods of time so we
often use computerized tests where we
ask the person to sit in front of a
computer and look at a series of things
on the computer screen and we want to
see how well they can maintain their
attention so for example paying
attention to letters presented on a
computer monitor you may have guessed
that this is actually one of the tests
actually the Connors continuous
performance test is one of the tests
that we use to diagnose as part of the
diagnosis for ADHD so if you're gonna
see a neuropsychologist for a diagnosis
potentially of attention deficit
disorder this is one way that we
objectively measure attention so I want
to show you a quick example of how this
test works actually I'll be showing you
in a moment it looks like it's not here
um okay hopefully if somewhere there um
verbal and visual memory another
important aspect of neuropsychological
functioning so what we have here is
first verbal memory test that we usually
ask somebody to remember a story or a
list of words and then maybe half an
hour later remember what the words were
or the story visual memory tests as you
might imagine require you to reproduce a
design for memory so this is something
that people really get overwhelmed by a
picture here of the actual eye of the
actual complexity of trying to reproduce
from
Maree a complex design it's actually not
that easy now another thing that we do
is we have something called the
executive functions now executive
functions as I said are is like it's a
complex term we usually call it an
umbrella term for a lot of these very
high-level cognitive abilities so these
are things like planning problem-solving
and impulse control so seeing what I say
here about executive functions you can
probably guess right now that this is
one of the cognitive abilities
neuropsychological abilities that tends
to be impacted in BPD this is the most
common one and I'll talk about what
these results are in a moment so how
might you use a neuropsychological
testing so there are lots of different
uses you know I've seen people with all
types of cognitive dysfunctions so
people who you know come in with brain
injuries related to playing hockey or
soccer I have people coming in to get a
more refined diagnosis of dementia so is
a dementia associated with Alzheimer's
or depression or both um but probably
what I see the most when it comes to BPD
is people talking about being worked up
fried diagnosis of ADHD or a learning
disorder so this might bring true for
people in the room in terms of having
this come up for people with BPD another
important piece of this is treatment
planning you know it's really important
for a clinician to know does somebody
have really significant memory problems
because if they do then maybe we should
be accommodating these by maybe using
memory aids in psychotherapy or maybe
giving them memory aids to take
medications I mean these are important
things that we might be kind of ignoring
that could be important and impacting
somebody's treatment and later I'll be
showing you some cases where this
definitely seems to be the case that
these types of problems are actually
impacting people's ability to engage
successfully in psychotherapy okay so
why do we care about cognition and BPD
it's probably a question that many
people ask well historically if we look
at some of the writing
early writings of people with BPD or
that we're suspected of having BPD um
there was a lot of talk about problems
with integrating information and you
know that these types of things might
interfere with treatment and so recent
research actually suggests well first of
all that if we look at people with BPD
who are being seen on an inpatient basis
presenting for you know really in crisis
situations that the two strongest
predictors of who those people end up
being with BPD their that end those two
strongest predictors of being seen for
inpatient psychiatric hospitalization
are suicidality and deficient cognitive
functioning and a very recent study
showed that neuropsychological
functioning so performance on these
types of tests actually helps us
understand who's going to drop out of
treatment so I'll be talking a little
bit about that in a moment okay so some
of the cognitive difficulties that we've
heard talked about in the literature in
these kind of descriptions of BPD have
been things like poor focus and
concentration problems with memory or if
they are remembering things okay that
maybe they're somewhat distorted I will
talk about what this actually looks like
in a moment impulsive behaviors have
been described not surprisingly and
difficulties with logical reasoning so
well we talked about cognition and BPD I
often get questions from family members
especially from parents who have a child
who's affected with the disorder asking
about the relationship between ADHD and
learning disorders and BPD and they do
share several features actually so on
the surface they share things like
impulsiveness emotional instability
difficulty controlling anger you know
these are things that on the surface
look very similar between the two
disorders and interestingly children who
have ADHD have been found to be five
times more likely to develop BPD in
adulthood
so there are good reasons to suspect
that maybe some people BPD have
difficulties with some of these
cognitive functions now I often get the
question as well well do people with BPD
what you know what's going on with this
relationship with ADHD if you have ADHD
or you're more likely to have BPD or if
you have BPD I mean are you more likely
to have ADHD
well the way I like to look at it is
that the brain systems that are involved
in regulating emotions which we often
associate with BPD are very similar on
the overlap considerably with a lot of
these cognitive functions I just talked
about attention concentration problem
solving and memory and so this is a
recent study that got a lot of media
attention where I actually looked at put
all these studies together that have
been done on BPD and brain imaging and
while people are processing negative
emotions what I found when it comes to
parts of the brain that are under active
is that the dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex which you see here in blue the
blue little blobs here means there's
less activity for people with BPD and
then you have something called a
subchannel
anterior cingulate which is right over
here another little blue blob these are
toward the front of the brain and tend
to be associated with obviously
regulating emotions but also with
attention and problem-solving and a lot
of these executive functions so really
these same brain systems are involved so
I don't like to see things as ADHD
versus BPD but the parts of the brain
that tend to be not functioning in the
same way as that are in healthy
individuals are involved in attention
and emotion regulation and it's okay to
think of it as ADHD and BPD but I like
to encourage the people that I see to
think about these all being related to
each other okay so we finally get to the
slide that I wanted to get to after
talking about all of these cognitive
functions what actually do we see in
people with BPD so one thing that I want
to point out here is that this this is
the base
synthesis of eleven different studies on
BPD that looked at neuropsychological
functioning but this is remember while
people are not emotionally disregulated
this is when people are stable and being
asked to complete all these different
tasks so this doesn't account for what
happens when somebody becomes
emotionally disregulated so at baseline
what we see across the seven different
cognitive domains is that first of all I
should say that all of these cognitive
domains attention processing speed so
this is how quickly can you actually
process information verbal memory visual
memory your visual spatial functioning
that I talked about kind of navigating
yourself cognitive flexibility the
ability to change your mind and planning
these are all actually somewhat less
efficient and people with BPD as
compared to individuals who don't have
BPD so all of these you know deficits I
like to call them inefficiencies because
they're not real deficits they're not
strong enough to be deficits are are
significant they really do exist in the
world but where we see the greatest
difficulties believe it or not or with
visual memory which surprised a lot of
people when this study came out um this
has to do with remember drawing
something and then remembering maybe 20
minutes later what is it that you just
drew and it's amazing to see what people
actually do that some people really
can't even remember at all that they
even drew something previously um and
those who do tend to really have
distorted images um and again I would
show you a little bit more some of these
things but they're copyrights Heth
uh-huh and then planning is something
that wasn't necessarily surprising here
that we actually have tests where we
have somebody build a tower for example
it's called the tower test um
and what you do is you ask them to place
these blocks and build this tower and we
can measure how efficiently they're
basically solving this problem and what
we found is that they have a hard time
really planning out what they're doing
so this was the first time that we
really see
evidence for clear difficulties when
somebody is emotionally stable somebody
BPD is emotionally stable okay so then
the question becomes well how might
these types of things affect treatment
unfortunately we don't know very much
just yet I mean a year from now I'd love
to be able to talk to everybody about
the results of this study that we're
doing in Toronto looking at treatment
and how these types of things might
affect treatment for people with BPD I
do have a little bit of information that
I'll tell you about in a moment but if
you think about these types of cognitive
abilities that I just described if
somebody with BPD is going to
effectively engage in treatment well
it's important that they're able to pay
attention right it's important for
anybody be able to pay attention if
you're gonna engage in something as
complex as psychotherapy um to be able
to concentrate you should be able to
remember what you did in in treatment
what happens if somebody comes in and
and you as a therapist have just spent
you know an hour talking to them and and
and processing a number of different
important parts of this
psychotherapeutic interaction maybe if
it's a DBT type of therapy then maybe
we're talking about skills that they
should be implementing in their daily
lives
what if they forget everything once they
leave your office I mean this is an
important thing to consider because it's
completely possible that this is what's
going on so memory obviously important
and executive functions if you're going
to use what you learned in psychotherapy
and this is assuming that you attended
to it and remembered it you have to be
able to problem-solve in those
particular situations maybe use these
these skills you've learned to control
your impulses to plan out what you're
going to be doing these are all really
important and it's kind of surprising we
know so little nobody's really looked at
this with BPD and a problem can arise
when any one of these specific cognitive
functions is effective so if you have a
problem with attention then you probably
can't remember what it is that you were
supposed to be paying attention to and
that will affect whether you can
actually use what you learn
in treatment so I want to talk here now
about some case examples because we
don't have data just yet about how these
things affect treatment but what are we
talking about are some individuals who
were referred to me for
neuropsychological testing as part of
their work up for DBT at the Centre for
Addiction and Mental Health in Toronto
so before I go into the details of these
individuals
I want to refresh people or teach people
if you're not familiar with it just yet
how we actually gauge how good somebody
is doing all these tests versus how
not-so-good people are doing on these
tests and we call these z-scores or if
you're from Canada we call it a Zed
score so if I say Zed just you know deal
with me so I want to refresh people's
minds for those who may have learned
this a z-score is a score that we use
that helps us understand where an
individual person that I have in my
office where do they lie with respect to
the general population so like I said
these tests have been given to hundreds
if not thousands of people so we know
what's average and we know what's not so
good and what's really good so an
average score I should say is zero okay
a z-score of zero means you're right in
the middle 50th percentile as a
neuropsychologist unfortunately we're
looking for the lower end of things so
you know are there certain problems that
might be explaining you know why
somebody isn't getting better in
treatment so we usually look for a Z
that's less than one negative one point
five do you think of a bell-shaped curve
it's kind of on the on the low end of
this so as you're looking at the first
peoples results I'll be presenting in a
moment I want you to look for a Z of
negative 1.5 as an indication of we
actually would call that a significant
deficit for an individual person now
anything above that you can see ranges
from low average up to average and then
even superior so keeping this in mind
and you all have it in front of you so
you can refer to it I want to first talk
about a male that I just saw probably
three months ago
he was a 25 year old young man a really
really sweet guy in his third year of
college and he was again referred for
DBT because of extensive self-harming
behaviors notably cutting and also
making suicidal threats to a number of
different people so he eventually was
hospitalized and he was hospitalized for
so long that he decided to drop out of
college because things were just too
difficult to manage at that time so he
came to see me and you know he really
presented as very anxious I really
wasn't sure whether he wanted treatment
it was so hard for him to get treatment
that he was at the point where he's like
okay I guess I'll kind of give this a
trial go through this assessment um and
then we'll see where I am and you know
maybe I'll commit to treatment but maybe
I won't so he talked a lot about you
know a history of parental abandonment
and his father left his family when he
was a young child and he talked
unfortunately a lot about extensive
physical abuse on which he said was at
the hands of his mother and that a lot
of this has shaped kind of the way that
he relates to people now especially
women so there's a lot of social anxiety
toward women so in addition to BPD he
was diagnosed with recurrent major
depression we do have a very
comprehensive workup on and he also had
some difficulties with alcohol abuse in
the past when he becomes significantly
dysregulated emotionally one thing that
he often turned to in the past was
alcohol and so it's important to
consider substance abuse when we talk
about somebody's cognitive functioning
and as I said he was really reluctant to
engage in psychotherapy for his
difficulties and I think a lot of it had
to do with having so limited access to
treatment in Toronto that he just didn't
want to even at the at this point
unfortunately really fight for the
treatment and we were able to get him
ahead of the waiting list and get him
into treatment but first I want to first
talk about what happened to him I want
to talk about um
his neuropsychological functioning so
one thing that I want to point out is
that we always get an estimate of
somebody's IQ when we evaluate somebody
and one thing that I don't like to hear
is a lot of people think well maybe you
know I'm just not smart enough you know
and um I'm you know that that's what's
going on here but it's not actually for
him he was still within the average
range
okay anywhere from here to here is
average um but most of the people that I
see with BPD on average are actually a
little bit higher than our healthy
individuals with regard to IQ so it's
not a problem of IQ that I don't know
what to do or I'm having you know I'm
not smart enough to do this it's not an
IQ problem instead if we look at each of
the cognitive or neuropsychological
domains that I presented earlier what we
see is that for example his ability to
process information is perfectly normal
he has good attention both brief and
sustained where we start to see some
lower scores moving toward that 1.5 mark
that I talked about is verbal memory
response inhibition his ability to
control his behavior and what we can see
is being really significantly impacted
it's planning so you might think about
what are some of the difficulties that
you'd expect in therapy with somebody
like this you know what would we expect
to see would he be planning out what he
should be doing on a weekly basis would
he be able to control his impulses as
well as somebody else who may be
objectively has good impulse control
would will he have a good he will only
be able to remember what you did in each
therapy session I think that all of this
is so important when we think about
planning treatment for these people so
despite his difficulties here he
actually expressed to me that he's maybe
a little more optimistic this time
around for treatment and by the time
that we finished our assessments with
him he really talked about being more
enthusiastic about his his prospects for
getting better with DBT so he scheduled
his first psychotherapy session but he
didn't attend the appointment okay so
maybe this isn't entirely surprising
considering his
you know his neuropsychological profile
and when the clinic coordinator
contacted him he basically stated that
he was no longer interested in therapy
so this was unfortunate and we're
obviously still trying to get him in and
seeing what we can do to kind of
motivate him to engage in this treatment
but there the study that I talked about
the one study that's actually been
published so far on BPD and treatment
found that planning and visual memory
are the greatest predictors the
strongest predictors of treatment
dropout so it's not entirely surprising
when we look at how poor his planning
abilities were and by the way this is
when he's emotionally stable you can
imagine how worse things might get when
he's you know experiencing some stress
um it's not entirely surprising given
the research that we actually see out
there all right so I have a second case
that I want to talk about and this is a
woman who came to see us as well for her
workup for DBT at CAMH in Toronto if
you've heard Shelley macmaine Sheldon
macmaine is the the coordinator of this
clinic and she was referred because of
extensive self-harming behaviors and
she's actually probably one of my
favorite people to be honest with you
that I've evaluated she was a really
outgoing individual um and she you know
at first I thought it was her being
neurotic you know when when she
scheduled her appointment to come see me
she called me over and over again saying
okay where exactly do I need to meet you
where does the bus drop me off on the
campus you know where do I go from here
and you'll see what that may have
actually been in a moment not just being
a little neurotic but you know we talked
about her case history she talked a lot
about having interpersonal problems
going back to childhood she said that
she couldn't even get on the waiting
list unfortunately for treatment in
Toronto and that finally getting this
hope to actually get into treatment was
a really really big deal for her and so
she was excited to finally be in on the
on at the end of the waiting list and to
get into the
treatment so she talked a lot about
interpersonal problems unemployment and
she attributed a lot of these things to
her emotion dysregulation um this is not
uncommon by the way for us to see people
who are chronically basically unemployed
have a hard time finding work and some
of the research that we've done so far
actually suggests that some of these
neuropsychological deficits might be
contributing to this but that'll be a
topic for another day now in addition to
BPD our assessments showed that she was
diagnosed with major depression alcohol
dependence so a big thing for her when
she was feeling emotionally disregulated
in the past was to turn to alcohol and
unfortunately when alcohol was no longer
an option for her because of the really
harmful consequences it was having for
her she turned to her self-harming
behaviors so you know it was kind of the
switching from one thing to another all
in a sense you know forms of self-harm
she also described PTSD related to
physical abuse from a romantic partner
in the past and paranoid personality
disorder so we could we already know
that she will have difficulties with
trust you know going into this okay so
when we look at her neuro psychological
profile it's quite different from the
young man that I just presented we can
see here that her IQ is actually high
within the average range so not
surprising for us to see people with
very high IQs yet difficulties you know
holding a job or being able to you know
really stick with treatments well what's
really going on is we can actually see a
big dip here when it comes to verbal
memory and especial especially visually
visual memory um so we see processing
speed attention planning response
inhibition all intact so what's going on
well the test a visual memory is
actually quite difficult and she really
distorted the image that that she had to
just to present to us she had a hard
time recalling the lists of words and
it's not so
then that after completing the
neuropsychological testing and I looked
at the results of it I thought wow she
has some really significant cognitive
difficulties I should say by the way
that we always give tests of effort so
it's not that she's just not trying we
actually give tests that see how hard
people are trying this is so these are
all valid performances this is actually
how she does on these tests not that
she's not trying so after she completed
the testing I got a phone call while
severy several phone calls later that
night and the next day because she
couldn't remember if she had actually
participated in a study of mine or if it
was another study and NW she was
actually talking about somebody else's
study at a completely different Hospital
so I could start to see here how memory
might be playing a role um and in
talking to her therapist I learned that
psychotherapy and by the way she's been
in therapy for about four months now I'm
in DBT has progressed somewhat slowly
slower than they would have liked and
one of the main themes was that she
tends to leave a lot of messages for her
therapist I actually got a lot of
messages to the next day saying I forgot
to tell you this I forgot to tell you've
had right and her therapist apparently
has a difficult time kind of managing
all these phone calls so it would be
nice to know how can we actually use
memory aids or other types of things
during the week in between therapy
sessions rather than kind of calling her
therapist multiple times to say oh I
remember this and this is really
important for me to say right I know
that it is important but maybe trying to
knowing that these could be problems and
you know planning ahead of time we can
avoid maybe some difficulties and maybe
psychotherapy would be even more
effective so and another big thing was
you know not knowing how to handle a
situation you know I often hear people
saying that I don't know what to do in
this situation and what our research
suggests is that they know that it's
actually in their their memory even
though it's not you know as great as we
might hope on average for these people
the information gets in there the hard
part is actually using the information
so it's not that they don't know it
or remember it the hard part is
retrieving it from their memory and
using it okay so some of the take-home
messages that I have then is that you
know BPD is associated with a range of
cognitive deficits and that no two
individuals necessarily will look the
same some people will have deficits with
memory and concentration other people
will have really difficult problems with
planning and impulse control and so we
can't say that everybody with BPD has
these problems in fact we found that
there's a good proportion of people I'd
say a good 25 to 30% of people who don't
show any significant deficits at all
actually so this is not common across
all people with BPD and no two people
look alike but what we can say is the
most frequently affected domains are
memory response inhibition and planning
and these deficits are really subserved
by many of the same brain systems that
are involved in regulating emotion so
usually we're talking about frontal
regions of the brain being responsible
for regulating emotions they're also
involved in regulating controlling
focusing attention now we talk about
treatment you know worse executive
functioning and visual memory in this
one study i bifur took at all in 2012
actually suggested that it's visual
memory and these executive functions if
you're do particularly worse on those
that is a predictor it helps us
understand who's gonna end up dropping
out of treatment people in terms of
people with BPD so it's you know there
might be a lot of potential here if we
can actually study this in a systematic
way and I would recommend to many of the
clinicians here today you know if
somebody comes to you and says you know
I do have memory problems I have a
really hard time paying attention to
trust your patient okay this is
something you know real for them and
might warrant a neuropsychological
evaluation and so an individualized
neuropsychological assessment might
actually really
with with treatment planning and could
improve the treatment outcomes for these
people and really briefly what I want to
say here is that the study that we're
doing is actually looking at DBT and
kind of how how cognition and brain
function might change through treatment
and if we're talking about DBT and the
mindfulness component of DBT but you
know this is really an attentional
intervention can people really use their
attentional skills in a more effective
way and if somebody is having problems
with concentration and distractibility
if you can actually improve their
attention through some of the things
that we do you know as part of therapy
if you can improve attention then
actually that has a good impact on
memory you can actually improve memory
as well so there are a lot of really
interesting ways that therapy can
actually take advantage of what we know
about cognitive deficits and BPD and
maybe improve them and improve therapy
hopefully outcomes for these people all
right so where are things going with
this research well we have as I said
this study B that's funded by the
American Foundation for Suicide
Prevention and we're incorporating the
scenario psychological testing that I've
already talked about and brain imaging
to see whether we can predict who with
BPD who is also self harming who's going
to benefit the most from DBT and how
might these things actually impact
treatment I think you know an important
question that hasn't been evaluated just
yet so look out in about a year or so if
we should have the results of this study
available and hopefully we've got some
interesting findings and another thing
that I want to talk about because this
is a study that we're running in our lab
right now in Toronto is that these
cognitive deficits that we talked about
in BPD might actually be heritable
within families so we have this small
pilot study we've now got probably 60
families in the study at this point um
we're actually looking at people who
have BPD and their first-degree
biological relatives and looking at
whether people
related to people's BPD by virtue of
being genetically related to them do we
see some very subtle cognitive
inefficiencies and the long story short
is that we have it seems that we do
actually very subtle not everybody
obviously so if your family member here
today this is on average okay um and
what we're finding is that there might
be difficulties with controlling
impulses memory and vigilance or
sustained attention so we can actually
use this information to potentially
identify genes that might be
contributing to BPD so a lot of
interesting things that don't
necessarily have a clinical application
but that could eventually help us
identifying causes all right so that is
everything I do want to acknowledge my
laboratory at the University of Toronto
Scarborough campus where all this
research is taking place and my primary
collaborator Sally macmaine and the BPD
clinic at CAMH in Toronto and this
research funded by AF SP and the
Canadian Institutes of Health Research
and last but not least really this
research wouldn't be possible with
people you know actively participating
in our research and so I want to thank
people with BPD their families who
really make this research possible thank
you
thank you dr. Roco we have an addition
to questions we have complements both to
you and dr. ball for these for these
very wonderful informative discussions
I've got a big stack of questions I'll
start going through there's some
overlapping questions in some of these
we could also bring to the panel at the
end we'll start with I've always worked
with the assumption that there that
stress anxiety impairs cognition do you
know of any research looking at
fluctuation in cognitive functioning
related to stress affective states and
then the question goes on but let's
start there yeah
that's a really great question the
reason it's so important is because
unfortunately right now all these
standardized tests that we use as
clinical neuropsychologist um they don't
really get at the heart of what's going
on with BPD frankly you know that under
conditions of stress that's often when
cognition is most significantly impacted
so what I'll say in terms of research
out there right now there are a few
studies that try to integrate emotion
with some of these cognitive tests for
the most part the results haven't been
that fruitful I think the reason is that
you know having somebody try to draw
something for example that's very
emotional from memory isn't really
what's going on I think that inducing a
mood you know being able to get greater
be able to go into the real world and
seeing what's going on with cognition
when people are emotionally disregulated
what we need to do so what I will say
quickly though is that um in my
laboratory at the University of Toronto
we actually have a brain imaging device
that is not an MRI okay it actually is
slapped on to the person's for have not
slapped on but you know put onto the
person's forehead nobody's gonna wanna
be in my research now after I said that
um but what we can do is actually Andy
uses infrared light I should say to
image the brain you can actually then
have the data that's you know while
you're imaging the brain downloaded to
your iPhone if you really wanted to and
be able to follow somebody or in their
everyday life so this is the kind of
research that we're gonna be doing over
the next few years trying to understand
how this might be playing
in the real world there is a question
about can you describe what memory aids
are to a decline to help a client with
BPD with the deficits so another very
good question there are actually people
working on and there's actually a lot of
work done with schizophrenia actually on
and memory and how we can improve
treatment adherence so making sure you
take your medications so some things
really it's common-sense stuff you know
and things like you know I actually
haven't been involved in psychotherapy
for a few years now as a
neuropsychologist but I can say that
I've heard people do is you know writing
things down you know at the end of a
psychotherapy session in the next
session reviewing what has been done
really memory aids can be things like
even pill boxes that people use to
remember take medications usually we
think of this associated with like
Alzheimer's disease but if it helps it
helps you know so really pragmatic
things usually it just comes down to
writing things down and reviewing things
the thing that I said earlier is that we
know that people with BPD even though
they might have a hard time recalling
information it's in there so as long as
you can find a cue to help the person
remember the skill or whatever it might
be they usually are able to retrieve it
from their memory so it's not that
they're completely forgetting things
it's in there it's just trying to use
some cue so that they can use to
recognize what skill they should be
using or what the memory was that
they've actually stored so I hope that
helps but we actually need more research
done in this area in terms of what would
be helpful for BPD this one is you've
discussed the neurocognitive deficits in
borderline personality disorder but how
do you tease out the impact of neuro
cognitive problems due to other comorbid
disorders for example in case number two
could it be related to the alcohol abuse
so it's another very good question and I
feel like you're old reviewers of my
papers right now but it's a very good
question so one issue with
the research that's done in this area is
that we don't have large enough sample
sizes to say okay let's look at these
people who have you know no substance
abuse history and those that that do and
comparing their cognitive functioning um
so the research that we're doing now
we're trying to get the largest sample
that's ever been studied so we want to
have at least a hundred people tested
but right now we're at about sixty so we
can't actually tease this these things
apart what I will say is that there have
been questions about substance use
disorders and PTSD and the research
suggests that's in terms of substance
use these probably are these the people
who have extensive histories of let's
say alcohol dependence or cocaine
dependence these are the types of drugs
or substances that tend to be associated
with worse cognitive functioning but I
should say that once somebody abstains
from a lot of these substances for a
long enough period of time
cognition tends to go back to normal you
know so we don't expect unless somebody
is currently actually currently has one
of these disorders that they would that
they that they would be affecting these
people and all the research that we do
we actually screen people out who have
these disorders currently in a way it's
actually a good thing because these
people say I really want to be in your
research so they'll actually abstain for
a month and it actually is kind of the
start to them getting on the road to
recovery with that in that respect and
I'll say about PTSD the jury's still out
but it overlaps a lot the
neuropsychological profile in PTSD
overlaps a lot with BPD and we still
need more research on this topic I wish
we could give you an answer but not just
yet this question is how do the visual
spatial impairments in BPD affect their
behavior would it be different than
individuals who have visual spacial
impairments but without BPD mm-hmm I
actually have never thought of this so
it's a good question um because when I
think about visual spatial abilities I'm
usually I was surprised but that they're
even impacted here right um what I would
say is that executive functions actually
do play a role
visual spatial abilities so if you think
about navigating your way like I did
from the New Haven hotel here um you
know you do need to be able to use your
problem-solving abilities you need to be
able to use a lot of these complex
thinking abilities to be able to
navigate you know to the to where we are
today so I think that it's probably
other functions that are related to
visual spatial abilities that are
actually having an impact and that's
very different from somebody who maybe
had a stroke that ends up really
affecting very strongly visual spatial
abilities you know when I see patients
with dementia and different types of you
know brain insults they will actually
have difficulties you know if I say
would you like to go to the cafeteria
for lunch now they I need to actually
walk them over because they actually
wouldn't be able to orient themselves in
space appropriately especially the more
severe ones so it's a little different I
would associate the BPD visual spatial
problems more to the problem-solving
abilities rather than what we see in
actual disorientation in space this is a
question can you comment on dissociation
as a cognitive deficit perhaps in
relation to some of these memory yeah so
you know what the research that I've
started to see coming up that's not
published yet but that I have reviewed
actually does suggest that those who
have dissociation might actually be the
worst off neuro cognitively we don't
have enough data on that just yet but
that is the research that's starting to
come out what is going on with
dissociation you know what's causing it
you know I'm not sure that that's a
hundred percent clear just yet what I
would say is that the people who have
disowned the more severe dissociation
tend to be those who describe the worst
difficulties with cognition and when we
test them it's confirmed through that
can you describe response inhibition and
then there's another question about for
case two is it possible the memory
deficits are actually deficits in
response inhibition
so in terms of response inhibition I
actually did and maybe I did actually
update these slides
um and didn't actually provide them here
what I actually presented was a test
this test called the Connors continuous
performance test where somebody needs to
look at a computer screen and every time
they see a letter of the alphabet which
can be any letter of the alphabet they
need to press a space bar
so it sounds pretty simple but these
things come up on the screen pretty
quickly
people don't like me when I ask them to
do this test I'll tell you right now and
you know what they have to do though is
every time they see the letter X they
have to not press the spacebar they've
to stop themselves that's a way that we
measure response inhibition one of the
ways that we measure response inhibition
in our laboratory
so it's can you stop yourself from doing
something that you're inclined to do so
we asked somebody to do this type of a
test not just for two or three minutes
we asked them to do it for over 10
minutes okay um sometimes people are
dozing off some people you know are
getting really angry at me well
thankfully it's my research assistants
who are doing it and not me anymore but
this is what we mean by response
inhibition so response inhibition
definitely plays a role in lots of other
cognitive functions I should say that
some people are just off the charts I
mean I showed you people who have pretty
reasonable neuropsychological profiles
some people z-scores are just way off
the charts on that test specifically
they can they literally cannot stop
themselves from pressing that button so
in the person that there's the second
case in terms of how response inhibition
might actually be impacting memory what
I would say is that for the tests that
we use for memory it's like a shopping
list okay will actually give somebody a
shopping list and we don't think that
the ability to control yourself
necessarily plays a role in your ability
to just kind of recall your shopping
list right um but it's possible maybe in
that moment that that person is really
anxious and they're having a hard time
inhibiting their mood or kind of
regulating their mood and that's
interfering with their memory so I can
see how maybe problems with emotion
regulation could be actually impacting a
lot of what's going on
here you know when you present somebody
with a huge list of words they usually
get anxious you know so if you have a
hard time controlling that anxiety then
I wouldn't be surprised if you're not
doing as well as you could be on that
test
are there any simple verbal memory tests
that could be used in outpatient offices
providers a very good question and I'm
for sexually there are some very
straightforward tests that are out there
I would recommend something like the
Hopkins verbal learning test that's one
that I'm actually talking about almost
like a shopping list in a way it has 12
words on it and three learning trials
and it's a really interesting test what
I will say is you're not going to detect
these memory problems using the
mini-mental State Examination you know
three words is just not enough in order
to evaluate this it's just not sensitive
enough and so I would recommend
definitely using a test that's more
extensive than you know kind of a simple
brief memory test and one of them as I
said is called the Hopkins verbal
learning test a longer test if you
really want to go there is called the
California verbal learning test and that
has 16 words and lots of other fun
things that your patients will not like
you asking them to do I don't like doing
a what our effort testing profiles like
in neuro psych testing with individuals
with BPD are they are high failure rates
very good question because I actually am
writing a paper on this right now and
this is what I found I found that in 50
people with BPD who are outpatients what
I found is that 10% of them have
questionable performance so we don't
really know why there's questionable
performance you know what their
motivation is I think it's just that
they maybe are having a hard time
concentrating or something like that on
these tests but they really are our test
of effort so what I would say is that
they're most people are trying and the
reason I think that that question is so
important is because so many clinicians
you know the stigma out there is that
these people are manipulating people
you you know they're untreatable but in
fact if we look at our tests our
objective tests are actually showing
that they're trying they're not they're
trying to you know you know pull a fast
one you know I've got memory problems
but I really don't do you know if you
test me we're finding that there really
are you know they're trying on these
tests and I think that alone will go a
long way I hope toward reducing stigma
that they're they're trying and in my
research protocol the people who aren't
trying our healthy controls actually
we're finding that people are just
saying oh yeah I want to be in your
research and then they end up failing
our test because they just want the
money from Huss um so it's actually our
healthy people who are failing the test
more frequently than our people with BPD
does your practice diagnose borderline
personality disorder from neuro psych
testing so that's a really good question
because I've gotten emails about this so
I actually am not involved in clinical
practice all of this is really an you
know related to the DBT clinic and
mainly for research what I will say
though is that you cannot no
neuropsychological profile is diagnostic
I know a lot of people like to say okay
look my neuropsychological profile looks
like that but there are a lot of people
who have depression or who have no
mental health history you know issues at
all and they might look like who
actually so it's never diagnostic even
for somebody with Alzheimer's disease
it's not diagnostic so what it does is
it's descriptive it tells us what are
some problems that people might have and
is it consistent with what we know about
people who have this diagnosis I like to
use it as I said for treatment planning
and also to assist with diagnosing
things like ADHD and learning disorders
because neuropsychological testing is
part of the diagnosis of that how my
cognitive deficits impact interpersonal
relationships
yes so much so one of my students is
actually looking at another aspect of
cognition that I'm not even talking
about today it has to do with it
processing emotions from in phases and
when I presented this research in Boston
two weeks ago people family members were
saying
you need to get this the word out there
about this the what our main finding was
this people's BPD looking at faces
actually process neutral faces in a very
different way than people who don't have
BPD they tend to actually see a negative
emotion in a neutral face and we
actually found that they have a hard
time recognizing disgust in faces which
is interesting considering disgust
signifies rejection and an anger as well
so in a different aspect of cognition
it's a social cognition so I think that
some of these things are contributing to
how people are actually interpreting
social cues like faces so the research
is suggesting that actually something
that's unique to BPD that you don't see
in schizophrenia bipolar disorder
because I've actually done research on
this and those disorders is
misinterpretation of neutral faces and
difficulty really identifying and
recognizing faces that are signifying
threat or or or rejection how can a
treater or family member address these
problems in perception cognition without
seeming to invalidate the experience of
someone with borderline given that
feeling invalidated may lead to more
dysregulation yeah it's a good question
and I have to give it you know give
credit to the to the therapists out
there who you know really are trying to
manage emotion dysregulation on the one
hand and then also you know cognitive
dysfunction um I found that you know in
my training validating that these are
real experiences you know that if you're
having memory problems to validate it
this is a real experience something I
didn't even get into here is that think
of the average BPD person if you've got
somebody who's got high IQ generally
speaking even if their memory is in the
average range let's say it's low any
average range if you have a really high
IQ you're gonna experience that as a
memory problem so I think it's important
to keep in mind that people with BPD
tend to have high IQs okay as I said my
research it's actually a little bit
higher
for BPD versus our healthy individuals
but if their memory is average they
experience that as a memory problem so
validating that maybe even pointing out
that you can have a high IQ and an
average menu menu memory and for you
that might actually be conspira-con it I
think to acknowledge it is the first
step in validating it and trying to work
in some of these you know memory aids
whoever if whatever it might be in
treatment and hopefully we'll have some
more you know empirical support for
types of AIDS you can use in treatment
in the future right now we don't really
have the science supporting it a final
question before our break you mentioned
that all patients with BPD do not have
the same cognitive deficits is there any
evidence that there are clusters within
BPD perhaps indicating that what we call
BPD is actually several distinct
disorders lumped together hmm yeah and
that and this is the reason that I
talked about having a large enough when
you're doing studies sample size right
you know fortunately unfortunately I'm
not sure what to say here in Toronto you
know we have so many people with BPD and
their family members who want to be in
our research part of it is because of
the lack of access to treatment and
people really wanting to be able to do
something so we're really fortunate I
have to say to have so many people
interested in the research and this is
why I have this slide here um when we
have enough people in our research we
can actually try to identify subgroups
and I know it's not the topic of today's
presentation but when I talk about these
different profiles and family members
and controls the research that I've done
actually suggests that those who have
the worst impulse control problems based
on neuropsych testing in terms of people
with BPD their relatives are more likely
to also have really bad impulse control
problems using the tests that I've
talked about and this is a suggestion
that maybe there's a subgroup of people
where there were response inhibition
impulse control is a core inheritable
component of the disorder and maybe
there are other aspects of cognition
memory attend
that differentiate these people from
another group of people where these are
the main problems so this is why I
talked about going beyond clinical uses
we can actually use this these cognitive
deficits and brain imaging markers as as
ways to maybe figure out if there are
subgroups of people with BPD and I think
most people would agree that probably
are and if you look at the research on
autism spectrum disorders schizophrenia
the research is showing once you go down
to this level beyond symptoms going down
to cognitive functioning and brain
imaging you see subgroups of people that
are probably related to different causes
for the disorder and that's what the way
that I use these types of tests in my
laboratory thank you dr. Roco
[Applause]